Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Guardians of the Galaxy 3 just
introduced Adam Warlock to the MCU James Gunn
has been hyping up how big his future is in the
upcoming movies even though he's leaving for the
DC Universe and a big part of that in the Marvel
Universe was the infinity watch in the aftermath
of Thanos in The Infinity Gauntlet so we'll break
it all down because it's all meant to be connected
I almost gave you a big spoiler but we've got
lots of plans ahead for for him in a great way if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we've still got the Guardians
of the Galaxy video game giveaway happening the
Star Wars giveaway going so I'll name a few more
winners during the video there's still a bunch
of free stuff that I have to give away so like
we'll just keep going until I've given it all
away and careful for spoilers from Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 if you haven't seen it yet we
have to talk about what happens to Adam Warlock
and his role in the MCU going forward but at the
end of the movie Adam Warlock turns against the
high evolutionary joining Rockets Guardians
of the Galaxy team just like he did in the
annihilation storyline the movie borrowed a lot
of plot elements from that with some changes of
the characters backstories like Adam Warlock was
the creation of the high evolutionary in the MCU
in the comics it was a group called The Enclave
so to explain Adam warlock's role in the future
of the MCU we need a quick history lesson for his
story through the infinity Saga and Thanos in the
comics a lot of his story is connected to thanos's
storyline in the comics in the movie Adam Warlock
story is like a speed run version of his earliest
comic book stories through the counter Earth Saga
which is a big high evolutionary story he forms a
contract with Adam Warlock to get rid of man Beast
one of his human animal hybrid Creations who had
taken over counter Earth and as part of that he
upgraded Adam Warlock giving him the Soul Stone
one of the Infinity Stones in his forehead that
storyline happened almost 20 years before the
Thanos Infinity Gauntlet storyline went down so
Adam Warlock kept the Soul Stone in his forehead
for most of that 20-year period he was designed to
be kind of like a space Jesus type of character
one of the most powerful Marvel characters with
the exception of people like Franklin Richards
who had like off the charts levels of power but
Adam Warlock had this evil Persona called
the Mages who would take over sometimes so
he'd show up in some stories as the villain
sometimes he'd show up as the hero in the MCU
they use the Thanos Infinity Gauntlet comic book
storyline for the infinity Saga of movies ending
with infinity war and Avengers endgame where
Thanos assembles The Infinity Gauntlet snaps
the universe then the the Hulk snapped them all
back there are a couple more snaps in there too
like there were many snaps that happened between
those movies but one of the big changes from the
original comics and there was a lot of complaints
about this from fans when this was all going down
when Infinity War was happening is that Adam
Warlock was a huge character in the final battle
where all the major Marvel heroes from all the
different teams Avengers X-Men celestials even
other Cosmic beings in the gods all face Thanos
and if you haven't read the original Adam Warlock
or Thanos Stories the funny thing is is that
was the second time that Adam Warlock fought
Thanos for the Infinity Stones there was a smaller
event that happened before The Infinity Gauntlet
storyline where Thanos just tried to assemble all
six Infinity Stones in snap Earth's sun kind of
like a mini snap event Adam Warlock assembles all
of Earth's Heroes and stops him and then later
Thanos assembles The Infinity Gauntlet and you
have The Infinity Gauntlet storyline the other
major change is that during that first original
Mini event they just called them the infinity gems
they didn't give them their separate identities
until the later Infinity Gauntlet storyline
when they became the Power Stone owned the Mind
Stone the Soul Stone the reality Stone the space
Stone in the time Stone so during the comic book
version of infinity war in endgame Adam Warlock
and the others were able to trick Thanos nebula
wound up getting The Infinity Gauntlet and tries
to claim revenge on him for abusing her her
whole life we kind of had a small version of
that during their battle on Titan during Infinity
war and while that's happening in the comics Adam
Warlock uses the chaos of that event to take
The Infinity Gauntlet for himself so when you
see the comic book panels of Adam Warlock with
The Infinity Gauntlet saying enough is enough
that's basically where this came from afterwards
Adam Warlock travels into the future and visits
Thanos on a paradise planet where he's on a farm
and he tells him that he's given up his quest for
power like Thanos lays down his armor they did
a version of that during Avengers end game on
his paradise Planet James Gunn did say early
on a couple years ago when he was writing the
script he did feel some pressure to introduce
Adam Warlock from the Marvel people like he
knew that they wanted to introduce the character
so it sounds like at some point early on Kevin
feige and the Marvel people were thinking about
including Adam warlock during Infinity war in
endgame but you have to imagine that pretty much
every character was in consideration the Russo
said that they had this white board across their
entire writer's room like all four walls were just
full of characters that they were thinking about
including the funny thing about that too is that
Mephisto like we make all the Mephisto jokes was
also originally supposed to be part of infinity
war and end game it's a deleted scene now because
Marvel's removed it from the newer versions of the
movie but if you go back and you watch Captain
America the First Avengers post-credits scene
the original version of the scene before Marvel
changed it when Nick Fury comes to recruit him for
the Avengers you see in the file there's a list of
all this Taco Mephisto connection to the Infinity
Stones most people watching this video probably
saw the original version in theaters but it was
so small that you probably had trouble seeing
this on screen during the comic book Infinity
Gauntlet storyline Mephisto was thanos's Ally so
he was a big part of that original storyline it
sounds like during Marvel phase one Marvel had
just planned on doing a more comic book accurate
version of infinity war in endgame and things just
changed along the way with all the different actor
changes and the minor story changes here and there
but after Thanos was defeated the Living Tribunal
declares that The Infinity Gauntlet can be used
no longer by anyone they had to get rid of all
the Infinity Stones there was also a deleted
scene during Infinity war with Doctor Strange
Thanos and the Living Tribunal they finally
wound up doing that character during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness when Dr Strange
and America Chavez were passing between universes
they passed by the Living Tribunal in the comics
after the Living Tribunal tells them to separate
the Infinity Stones and prevent anyone from using
them again Adam Warlock creates a team called the
infinity watch with each member being responsible
for watching over the remnants of the Infinity
Stones it is basically meant to be a team of
Marvel's most powerful characters within the MCU
Thanos atomized the Infinity Stones in corente
the ones Captain America had at the end of the
movie a lot of questions about this he returned
those to the original time periods to prevent
Nexus events so in present day right now the
Infinity Stones still exists they just exist in
atomized form they're like thin dust clouds of
Infinity Stones dispersed Across the Universe
someone could theoretically still collect their
Essence and reform them as Thanos and the ancient
ones said you can't actually destroy the Infinity
Stones permanently they create the flow of time if
they were destroyed all of reality would unravel
time would stop moving forward everything would
just collapse on itself the original Infinity
watch team was Adam Warlock Drax pip the troll
who's played by Patton Oswald they just introduced
him during the eternals movie Moondragon who was
drax's daughter in the comics now his daughter in
the MCU was supposed to have been killed by Thanos
but they could always say that one of philavel's
new sisters that Drax is caring for now like a
father becomes a version of moon dragon Thanos
himself also became part of that original comic
book team because he'd repented after everything
and Marvel tried to redeem Thanos a little bit
by having him join that original team like he was
trying to redeem himself by serving the universe
protecting the Infinity Stones The Infinity watch
team has had different rosters during different
eras the current incarnation of the team is Doctor
Strange Adam Warlock Star-Lord Black Widow Captain
Marvel in a daredevil character get this the
second version of stiltman of all people there
was an Easter egg for stiltman on the original
Daredevil Netflix TV show and Melvin Potter's
shop he created a stilt man's stilts there's still
a ton of stuff that happens to Adam Warlock in the
comics between the time he debuted and when he
formed the infinity watch team so for right now
as part of them adapting his early comic book Arc
like he's just continuing along that in the MCU
going forward he'll spend most of his time at
least initially with rockets Guardians of the
Galaxy team I don't think we're going to see Adam
Warlock teaming up with characters like Doctor
Strange the other super powerful Marvel characters
until Avengers Secret Wars just because of the way
they've shifted some of the comic book story and
changed some of the other character backstories
there's still several other major Comic Book teams
that Marvel can do now that they have pretty much
all the rights of their characters back like X-Men
Fantastic Four still have to share Spider-Man so
some problems with Spider-Man in there but aside
from the X-Men the Fantastic Four teams which we
know they're introducing pretty soon there's Young
Avengers there's the ultimates The Defenders like
a more comic book accurate version of The
Defenders they can do now they already did
a version the Illuminati recently there's also
the cabal on the other side of that they're also
introducing the Thunderbolts soon and there's a
bunch of spin-offs of existing teams like Adam
Warlock does become a part of the cosmic Avengers
eventually and speaking of his relationship with
Thanos in the comics Josh Brolin actually teased
more Thanos coming to the MCU so you can let me
know where you want to see Thanos showing up
again we just saw a bunch of alternate reality
versions show up during the what if series I think
they'll continue to do that in future seasons of
what if like what if season two and season three
my early theory for Live Action Thanos coming back
is actually doing a young version of Thanos during
an eternal story at some point in the future just
because they've been teasing the eternals at
the end of that movie meeting other eternals
from other planets so they haven't gotten into
his backstory in the eternals from Titan that
much yet they included a bunch of concept art
during Infinity War so it sounds like at some
point there were longer versions of the infinity
War scenes of Thanos talking about his backstory
in his childhood so I think they're just saving
that for future Eternal stories just because
they introduce Harry Styles Star Fox character
he is thanos's brother in the comics foreign
of Titan brother of Thanos it only makes sense
that if you're going to do his character again
he starts talking about his backstory and
he talks about his relationship with Thanos
they literally mentioned at the end of eternals
that he is thanos's brother so why wouldn't you
do more Thanos backstory that way let me know in
the comments what other big comic book teams do
you want to see them do in the MCU going forward
there's just so many options now that they pretty
much have all their characters for the most part
there's still a bunch of stuff that happened this
week on trying to do videos for everything so
if you have any requests just write them in
the comments below there'll be more Guardians
of the Galaxy three and more Spider-Man across
the spider-verse very soon congratulations
to the giveaway winners from my last couple
of videos is skewadi 71 Stuart liddell2513 and
Alana Smith 5615 please email me on the about
page of my channel on desktop so that I can get
your contact info everyone click here for my new
secret Invasion trailer video in Easter eggs and
click here for all my Guardians of the Galaxy 3
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!